good morning
and welcome to symposium one of the
brain initiative investigators meeting
i am grace wong a senior neuroscientist
at the johns hopkins applied physics
laboratory
i want to first thank the nih and the
organizing committee
for all of their hard work making this
virtual meeting a reality
i'm delighted to be moderating a
discussion of how we might achieve
reciprocal advances in dynamical systems
neuroscience and machine
learning over the first hour you will be
hearing brief talks from six
researchers conrad cording joseph monaco
conoco rajan zach pitko
brad pfeiffer and nathaniel dawe the
talks will be followed by a live q
a session with our speakers at any time
during the pre-recorded talks you are
encouraged to have questions in the q
a box and specify which presenter your
questions are directed to
we will answer audience questions in
addition to the general discussion
during q a
now theoretical neuroscience and
artificial intelligence have a long and
have long inspired each other important
commonest ancestor was the mcculloch and
pitts binary neuron model of logical
computation in the 1940s
which was combined with hebb's
exposition of associative synaptic
modification
to inspire rosenblatt's multi-layer
perceptron in the late 50s and 60s
this work set the stage for neural
approaches to ai
but neuroscience and ai diverged in the
ensuing decades
the past decade has seen surprising
progress in ai
that began with the advent to gpu
computing technology
and the availability of massive labeled
data sets
and deep convolutional networks inspired
by the feed forward architecture of the
ventral visual stream
in fact architectures and strain
training schemes such as transformers
and self-play
have produced world-changing feats in
language learning and game playing
however the machine this machine
learning paradigm of ai
though impressive is underpinned by
continuum
continuous incremental improvements of
architectures
optimizers and objective functions thus
it remains unclear whether this is the
road to human level features of
intelligence
including sampling efficiency
abstraction and generalization
so today we ask our panel can dynamical
neuroscience
the study of temporal change and
functional interactions across multiple
scales of neural activity
help us bridge this gap between today's
ai
and the flexible biological intelligence
demonstrated in the brain we have
convened
an excellent panel of theorists and
experimentalists
with diverse backgrounds in computer
science cognitive science
cognitive neuroscience neurobiology
physics
biophysics and neuroengineering to share
their perspectives
on reciprocal advances in neuroscience
and ai research
now i'm delighted to introduce our first
presenter of our symposium
professor conrad cording of the
university of pennsylvania
he will discuss how current dynamical
systems views
may be misleading welcome conrad
as today's meeting is about how the
dynamical systems neuroscience
interviews can inform machine learning i
thought it would be great to kick this
off by talking about the potential
problems that the field still has to
struggle with
and that their field is addressing at
the moment
so so let me first
summarize kind of the setup so um the
brain is undeniably a dynamical system
now we have 10 to the 10-ish neurons
they all to act each of them with maybe
thousands of neurons on average
but we cannot absorb that overall system
in fact we can only
record from a relatively small subset of
dimensions
and um and also if we record individual
anions they look like
it looks like they're very noisy now
they spike in this
points on noise on that and so on and so
forth and hence what we usually do is we
do dimensionality reduction and in this
lower dimensional space we can now
meaningfully analyze the dynamics of the
brain
so what has just happened there's a
scale transition
we have a small scale where the dynamics
happen and we have strong intuitions for
that and we just did a scale trend
transition where we went from this
microscopic scale
to a mesoscopic scale where we instead
look at the
relatively small number of components
we do not currently really understand
what we lose in that transition i make
this clear it's clear that there's
information lost as we go across those
scales but
which of the questions that are
meaningful at the microscopic level are
now still
meaningful and which ones are not it's a
central question to the field the scale
transition
some people argue that this scale
transition cannot meaningfully be done
and it's a central issue that we have to
grapple with and
it would be nice to see more work in
that direction so
first let's talk about this setting in
general in the field it is agreed
that neural representations are low
dimensional and we see
the literature full of graphs like that
how do we traditionally describe that
well we do linear dimensionality
reduction
singular value decomposition so what we
have here in the graph is on the y-axis
we have the variance explained by a
singular volume
and on the x-axis we have the index
of that of that variable and what we
find
is these graphs usually look what we see
here we have a few
really big singular values and then we
have like this tail that hangs over it
and we usually use some statistical
criterion to say well these are
significant and the others are not
but of course if this is the domain in
which we are
what would happen if we had more data
while we would be able to get
more components significant so in that
sense
this kind of analysis that is very
popular in the literature
does not ask what's the dimensionality
of the neural activity
it just asks can we give a lower bound
on the dimensionality of the data but
but that very much depends on how much
data we get and in fact
empirically as we get more and more data
from
the brain we find that we find more and
more than significant
and in fact here i want to just show
some really cool new analysis by carson
springer
and a good number of collaborators
where instead of the usual approach of
recording a small number of
relatively noisy signals they recorded
lots of signals at relatively
high data quality now on the x-axis of
the left clock here
we see the the dimension
of how many axes of the principal
components so
so basically the items to the left are
the early principal components the right
ones
are the high uh principal components so
what we find
isn't that they exist some significant
principal components and some
non-significant ones
now we find like a broad power law
with the coefficient very close to one
what that means is
that there's no sign of strong low
dimensionality here
and in fact in that same paper we see
good reasons why this is so so in
typical studies
we only give a very small number of
stimuli typical maybe 32 images or maybe
movements of the hand into four
different directions
and the and and
the principal components if we use this
impoverished lab type situations
we only need a very small number of them
to capture the vast majority of the
variants
but as soon as we go towards the real
world it looks like we need
far more dimensions now caveat
of course is we we cannot be sure about
that and let me highlight right
so we need more research on the question
of what's the dimensionality
it's central to our field not like if we
if
how far we can push various approaches
in dynamic
or neuroscience very much depends on how
low dimensional high dimensional
data is it's unclear at the moment how
low dimensional it is
most studies that are being cited to
argue that it is low
dimensional do not show it for example
there's a lot of decoding studies that
say
drive a brain machine interface they
often find that if we only take the
first few principal components
it does better than if we use all of
them well
the early ones have by definition high
signal to noise ratio
so it's kind of not a meaningful
comparison because it models the
dimensionality of the signal
to the properties of noise
and it would be really you know and also
it could be that
the brain is very low dimensional just
unfolds in a high dimensional space and
there is a
curved money fault in that space but
it's very hard to
know the nazis there so i think that
the we cannot be sure at the moment how
high or low dimensional
the brain is next thing is
even if the brain is relatively low
dimensional it's not sure if the
dimensions that we can pull out
really tell us the interesting
dimensions so what we did here is we
took a simulation of the
mos 6 502 and i should mention that is
eric jonas who did that
and we can record from all the
transistors in that microprocessor and
we understand pretty well how the
microprocessor work
works so what do we find well we do find
reflections of the clock signals
we do find reflections of say the fetch
and the read write signal in it
but that whole fine-grained dynamic of
how computation actually happens on the
microprocessor
we cannot meaningfully make sense by
looking at such data
no that doesn't mean that it's not
possible it just means that with the
techniques that we have at the moment
it's not possible so
do does looking at dimensionality
reduction
pull out the dimensions that are really
relevant to understand the system
we don't currently know that and we are
lacking theories that tell us why we
should believe that
there's also the problem of confounding
so um
in in this is something that occurs at
many layers it just as well exists for
uh for dynamical systems ideas so
let's take the model when conor drinks
beer it lowers the voltage of the
transistors in his
computer well there's supporting data
turns out that when conrad drinks beer
the voltage is on average lower than
when convert doesn't
so we could come up with models which
say converge spear drinking lowers the
voltage of that but the problem
is there's this of course a confounder
which is the time of the day affects
what conrad does
and the time of the day also affects if
he turns his computer on off
and therefore this confounder describes
both
and therefore any causal relationship i
would have described between two such
variables
can be meaningless the same thing is
true for the brain it could be
that we see relationship between
variables
we know by definition because we only
record a small number of dimensions of
the brain
that we miss dimensions that we don't
know about a lot of dimensions it can
very well be that these dimensions make
it happen
and that we see the reflection in our
low dimensional projections
now even if there wasn't a problem so
let me summarize now
the neurons view and the manifolds of
you so
if we describe the brain in terms of
neurons yes we have
far more but the interactions between
neurons are sparse and we kind of
understand the nature of that sparseness
we know how many
synapses a typical neuron does once we
take all those neurons and we dimension
how to reduce them
then the connectivity pattern that was
sparse in original neuron space
is very likely to be dense in the
manifold space
on the other hand manifolds are less
noisy as i mentioned before
than in the video neurons now individual
neurons can be feasibly per top whereas
with
money false that's almost impossible
what does that even mean to
perturb a manifold now in
individual neurons we might be able to
understand the non-linearity based on
models of say dendritic processing when
it comes to
manifolds it's very unclear how we
should think about what would be the
right
non-linearity for them and with neurons
we can
reason feasibly count them for manifolds
it's very hard to know how many we have
them
and i'd argue that we have very good
intuitions for arguing about neurons
and not so good in questions for
argument
over money faults and now
here's another problem so even if there
were lodi and we had inclusion causati
is a major problem
if we want to build a machine learning
system that somehow mimics the brain
is inspired by the brain we want to know
how information flows
at the moment there are no tools apart
from perturbations
that reveal the flow of information in
such networks as we usually aggregate
data across norms
we lose the small number of tools that
we currently have to get at causality
for example looking at the precise
timing between yards
what i'd argue is that we might instead
want to focus on cost functions learning
rules
and architectures but that's a different
talk look at the widgets at our paper
now to i want to skip over this i
apologize
now the question is what are the needs
of the machine learning field when it
comes to neuroscience
what we miss in machine learning is we
like good ways of handling causality
and we should focus on how the nervous
system
is so good at understanding the world
and the world in terms of cause and
effect
we like like good ways of life-long
learning
and how can we keep getting better why
do people not
catastrophically forget we we we like
good ways of active learning now like
babies know what's interesting what's
good for them we're really good at like
trying to soak up the information that's
good for us
[ __ ] machine learning systems are very
limited at that and
as we focus on dynamical systems
neuroscience it's important for us
to focus on the research that gets us
towards these questions
and after giving all these heart
problems that this talk was about
i'm very much looking forward to the
rest of the symposium and now after this
talk it's with great pleasure that i
anal
that i announced the talk of joe monaco
from johns hopkins university
who asked can transitory neurodynamics
verify
learning theories for brains and
machines
very much looking forward to his talk
thanks for kicking things off conrad i'd
like to thank grace wong and the
conference organizers for inviting me
i'm a theorist and computational
neuroscientist in this talk i'd like to
highlight several gaps in our dynamical
understanding of the brain
to address the question can transitory
neurodynamics unify learning theories
for brains and machines
to start i'd like to show a visual
contrast between learning processes and
artificial and biological neural
networks
on the left is a reduced visualization
of a standard convolutional network
being trained with backprop on the
benchmark mnist dataset
on the right a beautiful two foot a
beautiful two photon video
of mouse ca1 hippocampus is shown as the
mouse learns
an olfactory task the dense activation
across
the layers of the artificial network
stands in clear contrast to the sparse
activity in the hippocampal circuit
there are many more major differences
that could be listed which is what i've
done here
so the details could be argued over and
this is certainly not
exhaustive but there are many
potentially interesting gaps
in which neuroscience might be
translated to advances in ai
i've highlighted three in particular
that i'll focus on
here the first gap
related to timing points out the the
prevalence of local oscillations
and phenomena such as task dependent
modulation of phase coherence
in particular oscillatory coding by
spike timing or phase coding
has been extensively studied in the
hippocampus as the phenomenon of
theta phase recession brad pfeiffer's
talk later in the symposium will address
more on that
the second gap relates to observations
and theories that
recurrent connectivity in structured
networks can give rise to collective
emergent behaviors which are both
self-organizing and self-stabilizing
the dynamical notion here is that
memory retrieval is a state-space
trajectory that that searches and probes
the energy landscape of memory networks
the third gap is a deeper question
related to information versus meaning
for which i will speculate that
volitional interaction with the world
is what allows animals and biological
brains to construct meaning
two well-studied ideas from neuroscience
are are suggestive
first motor reference copy may be
interpreted as sampling a forward model
to predict the sensory consequences of
actions
second the sensory reference principle
implies that
that those forward predictions may help
separate external sensation from sensory
changes due to the self
due to self-driven actions so this
separation is critical to perception
and speculatively to the sense of agency
a tremendous amount of brain structure
is generally devoted to these motor
sensory feedback groups
as further speculation uh i would
consider that
these reaction predictions might be
implemented as dynamical high
dimensional state transits among
low dimensional attractors and
distributed memory networks those would
be networks with conjunctive
action perception encodings that have
been acquired through
experience so one question that i've
asked related to
timing is how do landmarks reset path
integration during
navigation and could resetting be
supported by oscillatory coding outside
of the hippocampus
this project was a collaboration with
tad blair at ucla who collected the data
and kitchen sang at johns hopkins a path
integration computes
spatial position relative to some
previous reference point thus
it naturally accumulates errors so
the internal representation for this
journey shown here on the left
may look like this green line where the
trajectory drifts off course over time
and needs to be corrected at the next
landmark
it's been unclear where path integration
is exactly computed
or how it is reset so tad recorded
theta rhythmic neurons from the
subcortical areas and in the lower two
rows of this diagram
and i focused on his data from lateral
septum here
which is the major subcortical
subcortical output
target of the hippocampus so
interestingly
i found cells like this with clear
spatial modulation of spiking
where spikes are shown as the red dots
on top of a trajectory
by averaging the activity at each
location in space we can create maps
so we can see that the standard firing
rate map up top shows the rate code of
the cell but the map on the bottom shows
the mean theta phase of spiking with a
clear
correspondence between the two i
quantified this with rate phase
correlations
revealing that higher firing rates were
strongly and monotonically associated
with earlier firing within the theta
cycle
so i called cells like this phasor cells
this is distinct from hippocampal phase
procession which has a highly asymmetric
rate-based relationship across a place
across the place field this symmetric
coupling
implied an intuitive phase coding
mechanism which i implemented in
dynamical bursting models
combining theta rhythmic inhibition with
external inputs as in the purple voltage
trace here
shown for both low input low input in
the top plot there and high
input on the bottom so sampling
different inputs
recapitulated that major cell
correlation then to create a large
network layer of model phasor cells for
the open arena
i trained a generative data driven model
and synthesized a thousand phaser cell
responses and some of which are shown
here in these great map phase map pairs
i did this in order to address the
question of learning so this
bursting target neuron i'm showing here
in the top left is a bit
noisy so its theta phase randomly drifts
around as a teaching signal
i created 64 sinusoidal gradings
corresponding to path integration with
differing spatial offsets
so training target neurons to these
patterns resulted in these responses
where each video frame that you can see
is the phase map
of one of these target neurons to
perform resetting these responses
must support reconstructing the animal's
trajectory
using bayesian decoding of burst phase a
sample trajectory in blue
was poorly reconstructed only along the
single preferred direction
instead when trained against all
different preferred directions
reconstruction was possible with much
higher fidelity
thus i theorized that an alternative
subcortical pathway for resetting
could operate using mechanisms of
collective synchrony
in discussing these results with
colleagues at johns hopkins applied
physics laboratory
one of them who is the moderator of our
symphosium today corey swann
thought the phase or cell mechanism
could be translated to the domain of
robotic control
we received an nsf brain initiative
award to study this possibility in the
context of robotic swarms
there are two key points to
understanding our swarming framework
first we analogized individual agents to
single neurons
such as phasor cells and groups of
agents to neural circuits
second relative motion was directly
realized as a form of heavy and learning
using spatial kernels to convert
pairwise distances between
agents into synaptic weights and vice
versa
the neural mechanisms consist of a
feedback loop
between a neural activation variable p
and a phase state
theta so agents integrate input from
cues
which are the purple shapes in the map
shown at the lower right here
and from rewards which are the gold
stars in that map
recurrent inputs from other visible
agents are phase coupled
such that similar phases mutually excite
the agents
and opposing phases suppress them thus
each agent is a simple model of rape
phase coupling similar in principle
to phasor cells to drive motion
we implemented voyage rule for the
recurrence forming matrix
shown at the top here and a feedboard
matrix allowing approach
to rewards those gold stars on the
bottom
so each of these two learning rules has
a relevant pre-synaptic variable
or pre-synaptic input and the activation
provides a co-synaptic
output so these are the two factors that
we need the correlation that we need
to try heavy and like learning via
oyo's rule now we can simply initiate
300 agents at different positions in the
environment
and they're shown as circles colored
according to phase so here's a
simulation
video in which you can see that the
initial clusters rapidly expand outwards
to form lines and arcs
so the agents are phase sorted within
these structures
and these structures self-organize in
complex patterns over time
note that every spatial configuration of
the agents corresponds to a new
attractor map
often several agents will mutually
synchronize to the same phase and
location forming a local fixed point
which can then destabilize due to nearby
agents
in this simulation only one gold star
reward is active at a time
so this is a dynamically changing
environment the resulting responsiveness
of the swarm
is akin to dynamically planning which is
a critical topic in autonomous control
no offline pre-training is necessary
this motion is an
is an online dynamical learning process
thus
swarm motion can be expressed as heavy
and learning in an oscillatory attractor
map network
with a small modification we can operate
a single agent the larger green circle
seen here on the left side of the map
this agent is guided by a swarm of
virtual particles
constituting the agent's internal mental
model
this paradigm completes the neuro to ai
loop by
bringing the neurally inspired
artificial system back into the standard
animal and amaze modeling paradigm of
theoretical neuroscience
this approach may benefit neuroscience
by visualizing neural circuit dynamics
dynamics in a completely new setting in
a way that improves our theoretical
intuition
and creativity i hope this illustrates
at least one way to reciprocally advance
learning theories
in brains and machines and with that
i'm really looking forward to the rest
of the symposium
the next speaker is kanika rajan from
the icon school of medicine at mount
sinai
who will be speaking about recurrent
neural network models of adaptive and
maladaptive state transitions
um i would like to begin by thanking the
organizers of this wonderful panel
uh thank you for the opportunity um
uh the title of my talk is multi-region
models
of adaptive and maladaptive state
transitions
and so a big thrust in my lab is to look
at data sets like this collected across
different nervous systems and ask the
following question
which is what are the circuit mechanisms
that are conserved when we go from a
small nervous system such as a larval
zebrafish
to a larger nervous system such as the
rodent even
non-human primate or monkeys and which
of them are and
and which which of them are different so
both ends of these questions are deeply
interesting to me as a theorist and
my colleagues in my lab but for the
purposes of today's talk i would like to
narrow this down
to this one question namely what circuit
changes
mediate the steep transition from active
coping to passive coping
in the larval superfish
so to get this my approach is to first
build and then analyze network models
that directly use these time series
measurements
that are obtained experimentally as
constraints so the models are built
by using the constraints of the
experiment directly
and then once i build these models i'm
able to get at circuit changes or
mechanisms
from reverse engineering these models
that i can't get from measurements alone
or the experimental colleagues can't
just discern from measurements alone
and so that's what i'm going to tell you
about today
so the first thing i do is to build
multi-region network models that are
able to capture the interactions both
within
individual regions as well as long-range
brain-wide
communication principles or inter-area
interactions
and so here's a very simple schematic of
what a single region like that would
look like
it's a recurrent network model where
each unit is a model neuron
they're all connected all to all through
the current connections
the connections between all the cell
pairs are expressed in terms of a
directed interaction matrix
which captures the pairwise strength of
the connection between or the
interaction
between individual units in this network
um
now i can extend this to two region
models in which i can take two recurrent
network models it's
built exactly like i explained before
and wire them together reciprocally
and the directed interaction matrix has
a slightly more complex structure
in which the within region connections
are are along the diagonal of this
matrix
and across region interactions are on
are the interactions that are in the
blocks that are
um on the off diagonal elements now i
can play this protect
play this game potentially brain wide
and i can build a multi-region rnn
that is as big as the whole brain of in
this case the larval zebrafish and
here's an example showing four of those
of what that would look like if i looked
at just four of those modules connected
reciprocally
and what the directed interaction matrix
within such a network would look like
so that's the first thing to do the
second thing to do is to take the
activity of each unit in this artificial
model network
which is initially irregular as you see
in the red trace on the right
and then train it to match a target
that's derived directly from the
experiment
so in models that i build the network is
usually as big as the size of the
experimental data set which is what you
see as the
as the n of the whole brain as you see
here in this case it's the order 10 to
the fourth number of units
and initially what starts off as a
regular activity from these artificial
networks is trained by using recursive
least squares
to match the calcium activity directly
obtained
experimentally so it's a directly data
constrained
network architecture and through the
process of learning the network
connectivity changes
through this delta jij term that you see
here so what does this act
this exercise by you right we've built a
model
that actually has the same level of
complexity as the experimental data set
in terms of number of neurons and the
and the time
series that it produces matches that of
the experimental dataset
what it buys you is three different
things um
and before i tell you what they are i
want to highlight a few papers that my
lab has written
very recently in terms of building
networks that are constrained by neural
dynamics as you see here
as well as recurrent networks that are
constrained by behavioral data as well
so we've done quite a lot of work in
this and we're really excited to push
this direction forward
so what are the things that such an
activity buys you right
it buys you three things one is you
build a model that produces realistic
neural dynamics so once it's trained
it's autonomously producing the dynamics
that are consistent with the experiment
you're not actually fitting a stationary
curve to anything
you're producing the entire dynamics
autonomously
the second thing is that you can look
under the hood of this trained network
and you're able to infer
directed interactions through the
matrices that i showed you
that are consistent with producing the
dynamics that were absorbed
experimentally
so so things like effective or
functional connectivity
except while it captures the entire
experiential state
and the third thing which is what's what
i'm going to focus on today is a new
direction that we're pushing
which is that this gives you the ability
to look at currents
due to the recurrence within and between
regions
and so this is something and and the
second two
the two things that i just mentioned
before the connections brainwide as well
as the currents due to the currents are
things that you can't
obtain um through measurements alone and
so what is the what do the currents look
like
and so here i'm showing you a very
specific example i'm showing you a three
region model that we just built
one with the hebenola one with the
graphi and one with the t
encephalon those are the three regions
in this network model
and a model like that gives you as i
said those two things kind of trivially
the first is the activity
that is similar to data because of
course that's what you're training the
network to do
the second thing you get this is
directed interaction matrix
in this case it contains three blocks
along the principal diagonal
the red block in this cartoon is
schematized by uh
represents the within habenula
connections the green block the graphic
connections
and the blue block the telencephalon
connections and the between regions are
in the off-diagonal elements
now the dot product of these two objects
gives you the third thing or the
currents
due to the current interactions now what
these currents can do if you look at the
term carefully
is by looking at just different
summations right along the
index j you can look at currents both
within a same region or
currents arriving into this region from
different areas
so for example if i'm considering just
the habenula by summing this
only over the vanilla neurons i can look
at the currents that a habenella neuron
receives from other habanero neurons
within the vanilla
or i can look at the currents that the
habenular receives from the raphae
or i can look at currents that are that
they have vanilla receives from the teal
encephalon
and so i can sort of separate the source
separate the overall activity obtained
experimentally into its different
components
and that's what i'm schematizing here
and what do they look like
right so the habanero to have vanilla
currents in this three region model
that's been
fit to um a shocked fish in this case
look like this so i'm plotting 2
200 herbal neurons as a function of time
and here just for ease of visualization
they're sorted by time of activation
the orange dots on top symbolize the the
time periods at which the shocks were
presented to this particular fish
the raphae to her vanilla currents look
like this here the units are actually
sorted in exactly the same order as the
first one
and the teal encephalon to the habenular
currents look like this they're again
sorted in the same order as the very
first of these graphs
collectively if you sum all of these
they should look like
the the overall currents experienced by
the by the hip envelope
so there's a there's a vast amount of
literature in doing dimensionality
reduction on experimental measurements
or calcium activity or
spiking activity or electrophysiology of
different kinds
what we're going to do now is use the
exact same techniques
except now we're going to apply them on
the source separated currents and derive
these three axes
so all we've done is do principal
components on these three component
currents
and derive those axes now we can take
the activity
recorded experimentally and project them
onto this
new coordinate system and that's what
that looks like
so now i've projected so that's what the
black trajectory
is is the activity is the overall
activity
of this particular shocked fish and on
top are the
are different dots that are that are
colored by whether they arrive
early in the experiment or they'll
arrive late in the experiment
and something surprising happens here as
soon as we plot the
plot the data like this it looks as
though the early shocks
are mostly um the early shocks
influence the trajectory in the rapid to
have vanilla subspace
and it's only later on in the experiment
or the experiential state
that they have been allowed to have
vanilla subspace and the teal encephalon
to have vanilla subspace get populated
so what we're able to do is to look at
things like inter
area time inter area effects such as
timing
so what i'm suggesting here is that the
early part or the
active coping phase of the behavior as
you see here i've brought back the
behavior
diagram where the control fish whips its
tail vigorously to avoid the first shock
that seems to be influenced mostly by
currents
flowing from the raphe into the venula
and the later
part of the passive coping is is driven
mostly by the hibernate
vanilla and telencephalon to have been
occupation of the subspaces so we're
currently working on several manuscripts
uh that are related to this one on the
methods and one on applying that to the
to the fish data
but in our view looking at uh source
d mixed input currents that reveal these
interesting inter area effects
is much more informative than looking at
the raw activity of the habenular
neurons
the average activity of these of these
neurons or the much more traditional way
of just
projecting the activity onto the
principal components
which is which is the much more
traditional view
now if i look at the same exact currents
in terms of time
what you see here is again a stark
difference between the control
fish and the shocked fish which is what
you see here now
the gray is just smooth movement or the
activity or the
tail whips that have been just smooth
for ease of view
and if you look at the shocked fish with
me for a second you see that at some
point the movements have ceased
now in in comparison with the control
fish
the trend that we looked at in the
overall 3d plot
seems to be that the active coping or
the increase in activity of the of the
movement
seems to be driven much more by the
raphael habenula engagement or the
current as you see in the average
ramping
in the green and it's only later on or
the passive coping
uh that seems to be influenced by the
habenula to have vanilla and the teal
encephalon to have been an occurrence
and there's no such a clear separation
between the three
in the control fish in which the
movements continue pretty much
throughout throughout the experiential
state
and so with that i would like to uh once
again
thank my colleagues and collaborators
particularly matt
camille and jean on the theory side and
tyler and aaron from the carl dice roth
lab from the experimental side
i would like to thank the brain
initiative for their ro1
so early in the formation of the rajan
lab
and with their without their help and
support and their faith
none of this would have been possible so
go brain initiative
uh before i wrap up um i would like to
dedicate
all my work to my parents whom i lost
very recently
they were my biggest supporters and the
biggest
allies to our scientific and
um and all my work uh with that i would
like to say one more thing which is that
we
if anybody is interested in work of this
nature in
in understanding how mechanisms arise by
building network models that are
constrained by data and reverse
engineering them
then please join us we're hiring
aggressively um
and with that i would um i will leave it
there
i want to introduce the next speaker
who's zach bitko
from baylor college of medicine um and
he's going to be telling us about
algorithmic dynamics in population codes
so take it away zach hi everyone
i'm going to talk about algorithmic
dynamics in population codes
the central claim here is that when
trying to understand the brain we can
best
interpret and generalize its
computational dynamics
if we use task relevant coordinates
within the neural populations
what you see here is a little cartoon of
a neural manifold
and the activity of the neurons are
proceeding through this
wiggly black line and we decompose
that those dynamics into two different
sets of coordinates one
relevant for a task and the other
irrelevant
so the irrelevant ones are going up and
down in this picture
tracing out a ribbon as the task
relevant coordinates
follow along this s curve here
which particular value you take in the
vertical direction the task irrelevant
direction
doesn't matter and so we can imagine
doing a targeted dimensionality
reduction where we
squish that ribbon down to just the
curve
and those are the computational dynamics
that we need to characterize
why is this the best description well
it's because of equivalence classes of
computations
from the representational point of view
we have many neurons that are tuned to
many variables that is it's a
distributed code
and those neurons are redundant so they
carry the same information
and it doesn't matter which particular
ones you pick whether you pick
these neurons that carry that
information or some other neurons or
some average of the two so we can
compress that information down
and remove the redundancy by looking at
the encoded representation
with respect to the task now
transformation wise
we know that neural networks can
approximate any function given enough
resources
that's universality and conversely any
function could be computable
in many different ways by a neural
network that's
degeneracy so do we precisely care which
way it's actually computed
i think computationally we don't and it
gives us greater understanding if we
take the more abstract point of view
here's an example of this
let's say we wanted to compute a
quadratic function now that
nonlinearity could be implemented
through literal
quadratic nonlinearities on neurons and
you add them together and you get the
answer you want
or you could use a bunch of piecewise
linear functions
with thresholds that are uniformly
distributed and if you add those
together
then you get that same quadratic
function at least a close piecewise
approximation to it
now what structure should we be looking
for and what variables do we care about
there's a hypothesis that the brain is
matched to the world
that through evolution and development
and experience
it has come up with a model of the world
that's useful for its actions
and here we follow that hypothesis and
we say that the brain
approximates probabilistic inference
on a generative model of the world and
here we'll add a little bit of new stuff
uh using nonlinear message passing
in redundant neuronal populations okay
so i'm going to talk more about what
this non-linear message passing is
first of all when you're accounting for
all the structure in the world or all
the possibilities that you might need to
do inference over
not anything is possible and so the
brain should and does
use structure one natural framework for
thinking about that is probabilistic
graphical models
which we can use to simplify a joint
distribution over many variables given
some observations o
with this s being the state of the world
and we simplify that by
looking at interactions between those
variables
statistical interactions this allows us
to
simplify the whole distribution to
smaller pieces
with using this conditional independence
relationships
now once we have that representation
that's much more compact than an
arbitrary distribution but it's still
hard to figure out
what you need to do with the variables
of interest and that's because not
everything matters
so you have to marginalize you have to
essentially ignore
the variables that are not relevant for
the task at hand
and accounting for all of the
variability of other things that might
have influenced the task variable
that's what's hard so this is something
we need some kind of algorithm for
and this is where message passing
inference is actually very valuable
this is an approximate inference and
what it does is takes
the local evidence the observations that
you get
and summarize that for each variable and
figure out how that variable is going to
affect the neighbors
send that information along the graph of
directly interacting variables
and then iteratively update that process
with new information as it comes in or
as it spreads through the graph
the the consequence of this is that
message passing will localize
information at the variables that are
relevant
so that they are actionable you
probably already know some message
passing algorithms this general category
of algorithms includes mean field
belief propagation expectation
propagation even gibbs sampling is a
stochastic
message passing function algorithm and
each message passing function is defined
by its own
non-linear function updates so what is
the brain's
nonlinear function how can we
characterize that
what we need to do is from neural data
and its input
to recover how the variables are encoded
that is the representation
which variables interact and how
that describes the implicit graphical
model that the brain creates about the
task
or tasks and crucially how those
interactions are used
that is what is the message passing
algorithm that defines how information
flows through the graph
according to the strengths of the
interactions there
how is this remotely possible i mean
i've just described a
general purpose implicit nonlinear
dynamical system how is that not
dramatically under constrained well
it's it's constrained appropriately and
identifiable because
we have assumed a global algorithmic
symmetry in asserting that there exists
a message passing algorithm
and i would say that this is actually
essential for any kind of
understanding of an algorithm in the
brain what does it mean to understand
something
it means that there is some algorithm
which is shared across many different
aspects of brain computations
and so we're sort of formalizing this
mathematically
in a way that makes it identifiable to
say what is the algorithm
here's a cartoon of how that would work
how you get this
implicit message functions we have some
neural activity which are going through
whatever dynamics they do
and some special patterns represent
different task variables in the world
here is a variable the green variable
and then other patterns will have their
own representations their own encoding
of something else that they're
representing
and as information flows through the
neural dynamics
over here that corresponds to
information flowing on this implicit
graphical model
which allows probability distributions
to interact with each other
probabilities about
subsets of variables at a time these
correspond so an example application of
this would be
let's say you're looking at something
which is uh difficult to discern
and you have a couple of uh edges
in an image which are described by some
orientation
you can get more information about
what's missing between them
where you can fill in the blanks or you
can resolve some of the ambiguity
by allowing information to flow across
space according to this graphical model
i show here a couple of scatter plots
illustrating that for a simulated brain
we're actually able to do this we have
a completely distributed nonlinear
dynamical system that implements
some inference algorithm and we do
uh we follow some expectation
maximization algorithm when
we're able to recover both a good
description of the neural dynamics
and a good description of the latent
variables
uh shown in blue you get this diagonal
the inferred
and the true match that's where you get
the diagonal
so to conclude we have this this way of
thinking about computational dynamics in
neuroscience that might be informative
about machine learning
because we can learn what kind of tricks
the brain uses
in its implicit inferences operating on
its model of the world
so the computational level this is
approximate inference
that uses um it's a mathematical
framework for what
agents might compute while they're
trying to perform tasks
and at the algorithmic level we have
this recoding dynamics where the the
code itself is changing what what the
task variables represent
is changing as they pass information
around and refine their estimates of the
world
and this is because latent variables are
represented across neurons
and the nonlinear dynamics performs
implicit inference
so this is um a little overview of some
work that you can read about in some
other sources
uh if you look up my name and this is
the
contributions have been coming from a
bunch of people in my lab including
uh raj ki jung yoon chen li young
and jolie and collaborators uh scott
linderman and dora angelaki
as well as several other people who have
been influential in thinking about these
problems
uh thanks to the funding and thanks for
your attention
and next up we have brad pfeiffer
from ut southwest who is going to tell
us about
hippocampal replay dynamics
hi i'm brad pfeiffer i want to start off
by thanking grace and the other
organizers for putting together this
meeting and for giving me the
opportunity to talk today
the people that were involved in this
project are among the wong she's a
senior graduate student in my lab who
performed many of the analyses for this
project
and the data that were used in this
project were generated by myself when i
was a postdoc with david foster
and he's very graciously allowed me to
take these data with me into my own lab
so imagine a sequence of reciprocally
connected neurons shown here
imagine that these this population
neurons is repeatedly and reliably
activated
in the following pattern abcdefgh what
we understand about spike timing
dependent plasticity is that if
presynaptic neural activity precedes
postsynaptic neural output
you should potentiate that synaptic
connection so in this example you should
potentiate the forwards
sequence that was just expressed this is
obviously very useful for prospective
evaluation
so at some point in the future if neuron
a fires an action potential
uh through a synfire chain like activity
pattern you might reactivate neuron h
which would allow the neural network to
make a prediction about what is upcoming
however spiketime imprint elasticity has
a depression component as well so that
if post-synaptic neural activity
precedes
presynaptic neural output what you
should do is weaken that synaptic
connection so
this makes it very challenging to to
imagine how the hippocampal circuit
might
retrospectively evaluate the causes of
some
current reward or or negative salience
and yet we know that during periods of
rest during shark wave ripples the
hippocampal circuit is very good
at generating reverse ordered sequences
in a phenomenon called reverse replay
and although many models have been put
forth trying to explain how one might
achieve reverse replay i think it's safe
to say that we don't fully understand
how a neural network can generate
reverse ordered sequences
following four's ordered activity
patterns and this is what our project
will be focused on so theta sequences
are an ongoing oscillation within the
hippocampus and other brain regions that
are about 10 hertz
these organized patterns in the
hippocampus at least have placed cells
into specific sequences as shown here on
the bottom the y-axis position on a
linear track across
time the black line is the rat's actual
physical position as it runs in this
case from the bottom to the top of this
linear track
and the color code is the result of a
probabilistic decoding algorithm
so this is the posterior probability
basically the location of highest
representation
in the brain at any point in time and
hopefully you can appreciate that these
data oscillations are organizing
hippocampal sequences
into these sweeps of spatial information
that progress
ahead of the rat on virtually every
theta oscillation
allowing for perspective representation
and these sequences seem ideal for
establishing synaptic plasticity across
a neural network in the forwards
direction
but labs such as laura colgan and david
redish have suggested that theta
sequences may
also encode some kind of retrospective
encoding and we wanted to see if we
could identify some
features of retrospective uh
representation in in our own data
so we decoded data from several rats
where we had recorded from several
hundred simultaneous
uh place cells and here is a result of
the decoding for one
small epoch of time here are three
consecutive theta oscillations
and what i'm showing you is the result
of the probabilistic decoding algorithm
this is the posterior probability
um so uh these are these have all been
normalized according to the rats
physical location at the time of the
decoding so 0
is always the rat's current location
positive values are ahead of the rat and
negative values are behind the rat
and you can see these sweeps of activity
representing
perspective evaluation on every theta
oscillation but hopefully you can also
appreciate there's this
negative this reverse component on each
one of these data oscillations
this is also true in the open field it's
a little bit more noisy because we're
compressing a two-dimensional
environment down into a single dimension
but still
positive values are ahead of the animal
negative values are behind the animal
and you can see this check mark-like
pattern where each data oscillation
has a reverse component followed by this
larger forward sweep
those are not rare events we see these
in every single rat
in every behavioral paradigm on
virtually every theta oscillation
and here's the average across all of the
many tens of thousands of theta
oscillations that we've analyzed
we've restricted our analysis only the
times when the writers running 10
centimeters per second or faster
in either open field or linear track
sessions and hopefully you can see just
by eye there appear to be two distinct
components to these theta oscillations
if you decode with a sufficiently large
number of place cells
we can identify maximum and minimum
posterior probabilities across these uh
these windows of decoding
and these uh this is basically a
representation of the quality or the
accuracy of the spatial decoding
at any point in time and we can use
these minima to uh
define analysis windows so that we're
using the data to define these analysis
windows rather than defining them
arbitrarily
and we can then quantify various aspects
of spatial representation within these
analysis windows
and we can see that the there's a
clearly a reverse window that encodes a
backwards
sweep of spatial information and this
canonical forward window that has been
well studied by other labs
importantly the reverse window moves
backward
faster than the rat is physically
running forward so it's not the case
that the the hippocampus is representing
a static location
that the rat is running through but
rather this is
on every theta oscillation the
hippocampus is iteratively encoding
as actively encoding a backwards
evaluation of what just happened
followed by a forward's prediction of
what might be upcoming
we can of course quantify statistical
significance in both the forward and the
reverse window and both of those
pass forward or reverse are
statistically unlikely to have arisen by
chance
next we want to ask what might be the
underlying mechanism
for the encoding of this novel reverse
component we were struck by the fact
that the reverse window of the theta
oscillation
comes at a phase of theta the peak of
theta associated with minimal firing
activity across the hippocampal network
so here's a
firing rate across theta phase plot for
a typical hippocampal place cell
you can see this knowledge relatively
inactive during this reverse window so
we wondered if perhaps there was a
sub-population of hippocampal place
cells that might be selectively active
during that window
and that's of course what we found most
cells that we looked at showed a
unimodal relationship
between firing rate and theta phase and
they were inactive during the reverse
window
but we also saw a relatively large
minority of cells that we called bimodal
cells
that fired twice in every single theta
oscillation and one of these peaks
was specifically associated with the
reverse window of the theta oscillation
by the way bimodal cells have been shown
previously in work from yuri vujaki's
lab
and they identified that cells that
reside in the deep portion of the primal
cell body layer typically fired twice in
every theta oscillation and we have
other evidence to suggest that
bimodal cells in our data are very
likely uh the same deep primal neurons
across our data set we see that about a
third of the neurons that we record
regardless of rad and regardless of
behavioral uh
behavior type are bimodal cells i'm not
going to show the data but the
backwards component of the theta
oscillation is very heavily
almost exclusively driven by the
activity of these bimodal cells
bimodal cells are more likely to
participate in replay than unimodal
cells and if you just look at activity
of bimodal cells
they are more likely to participate in
reverse replay than in forage replace
suggesting that the activity of these
cells
during that reverse theta oscillate the
reverse component of the theta
oscillation
might establish synaptic plasticity
which allows for this sort of
retrospective evaluation during offline
periods
we then wanted to ask what is the
underlying cellular mechanism that
allows for the expression of this
reverse component a lot of work has been
done studying the forward component of
theta oscillation it's believed that
phase
precession might underlie that forwards
component
as shown in this diagram from a paper
from bruce mcnaughton's lab
so phase precession is the phenomenon
where as a rat runs through a place
field the cell fires earlier and earlier
in consecutive theta oscillations and at
a population level
that generates sort of for free these
forward sequences
so we wanted a phase procession might
underlie the reverse component
and that's exactly what we found
unimodal cells shown here
uh display a clear phase precession
phenotype so as the rat runs through the
place field uh this cell fires
these cells fire earlier and earlier in
their uh in the theta phase
however bimodal cells show two distinct
clouds of activity as the route runs
through the place field
one that displays canonical phase
precession and one that displays phase
procession
we again define windows of analysis
based on minimum and firing rates across
data phase
and we can quantify statistical
significance and we see that the phase
procession component is indeed more
positively sloped than you would expect
by statistical chance
all right finally in the last few
seconds let me just emphasize that the
forward and reverse windows
appear to be statistically independent
of one another so if we rank each state
of oscillation
simply by the amount of firing in the
reverse window or the forward window
we can then quantify various aspects of
spatial representation
and i don't have time to go through
these data but basically when we rank
them by
activity in the forwards window the
quality of the forge window
improves but the quality of the reverse
window does not change or
if we do the opposite if we rank them by
the activity in the reverse window the
reverse window improves
but the quality of the forward window
diminishes suggesting that there's an
independence or in some cases
an anti-correlation between the quality
or the activity
in the forward and reverse window
suggesting that these two
types of activity are driven by distinct
circuit level inputs
all right so to very quickly summarize
we see data sequences encode both
forward and reverse sequences
the reverse component is driven largely
by the activity of bimodal cells
bimodal cells encode this reverse
component via phase procession
and the forward and the reverse windows
appear to be statistically independent
of one another suggesting that they are
driven by distinct synaptic inputs
these are the people in my lab these are
my funding sources thank you very much
for your attention
the next speaker is going to be
nathaniel dahl he is the whole professor
in computational and theoretical
neuroscience at princeton university
and his talk is entitled balancing
flexibility and reuse of computation
and reinforcement learning thanks
okay today i'm gonna give a very quick
overview
of some computational modeling i've been
working on with iem array
um it's available as a preprint here if
you'd like to see the details
so i study how the brain solves trial
and error choice problems what computer
scientists call reinforcement learning
um so in general the task force didn't
have multiple steps
like mazes like this one where you have
to make a series of turns to find the
goal
um and both organisms and computers um
need to
solve an objective function unlike this
one
um that adds up rewards uh over multiple
steps over different trajectories
um and solving or learning or computing
this function
uh turns out to be sufficient for
finding the best actions it says how
much reward to effect for different
possible long-run consequent factions
but this involves a lot of computation
um and one issue that's gotten more
attention biology than engineering i
think is that
organisms need to sort of autonomously
manage this computation to decide when
it's worth doing
uh and when you trade off against
shortcuts that involve
reusing previously computed actions but
maybe inflexible and make mistakes
so for instance we have computationally
heavy so-called model-based strategies
that
literally um solve this equation by
iteratively enumerating different
possible trajectories and adding up
rewards like sort of step-by-step mental
simulation
um in the spatial case these are
associated with non-local activity and
hippocampus as i think
brad will have just talked about this
gives the organism flexibility
um to say plan new paths when
circumstances or goals change so for
instance i'm trained hungry
for the cheese but tested thirsty so i
have to go somewhere else
i can figure out how to do that on the
other hand
the classic account of dopamine and
temporal difference learning
is basically model free it works by
storing
already computed values for different
actions over the long run
um that's computationally less demanding
um but it means that
it will make mistakes if you uh if you
tested the different circumstances that
was trained it will make
it chooses the wrong action um so the
trade-off between these two modes of
sort of flexible versus flexible choice
and computation has been a rich area for
us it's helped us to understand i think
issues like habits and compulsion and
automaticity
however um to make this all work better
um we'd like to find kind of in-between
strategies to strike some better balance
between computation
on one hand and reuse on the other uh
and a particular sort of make planning
work better
so in particular many researchers looked
at what's called temporal abstraction
like representing your model of the
dynamics of the task in a way that
aggregates over multiple steps
this would allow you to simulate the
long run value of candidate actions
using fewer steps of computation the
problem with this actually both for
computer scientists and for biologists
is that as you can actually see in this
objective function um
because i need to choose actions at
every step a little step in the maze
right
like each left or right branch point um
the longer run trajectory following any
particular action
actually isn't stable it depends on all
the subsequent choices too
so um the future path that go left at
the first step depends what i do later
which kind of where i'm trying to go my
goals are so this means that the long
run model actually isn't
easily reusable across tasks
even though it seems like they're useful
to do but that's what we thought
um it turns out there actually is a
surprisingly good approximation of this
problem
which actually has been used more in
control theory or control engineering
than an artificial intelligence um so
it's a simple linear equation
um here that you can approximate this
long run value of the
v star of the situation interaction by a
single matrix multiplication
so it's a matrix m uh times some vector
x r where
r gives you the sort of goals or rewards
that you're trying to
find how each location is rewarding um
and this is like a single step of a
neural network right it's a matrix
vector
um so what's m um
m sort of briefly encodes this long run
dynamics right it encodes
multiple future steps of where you're
likely to end up following a particular
location
but it does so under a default set of
assumptions about what
actions you're going to take at each
subsequent step like choosing randomly
and it turns out that because the
exponential's in this equation it's able
to sort of jointly optimize all the
actions to compute v
star for whatever it is you should do
for some particular rewards
um all at once by sort of relaxing away
from that default policy
um so in short if we can learn this long
run map m or compute it um
then we can reuse it over and over again
to plan new paths
even if the rewards change um
so just to give you some quick examples
of how that works um
so the first and most direct example
that i just talked about right so first
in psychology
um we often study how animals or people
are able to
use their representations of task maps
to find new actions um
by changing the rewards using
devaluations or latent learning tasks
like the hungry to thirsty example so
here's an example
where there's a team maze where both
sides were initially rewarded and the
simulated agent goes both ways at first
uh but then one of the sides is shocked
and the idea is the animal has to replan
a new policy that only goes right
avoids the shock 7 um and then url can
do this directly as you can just see
from the equation because all you have
to do is substitute the new bad state in
the r vector
and m times r gives you the very times x
bar gives you the correct paths
automatically as you see here um so this
class of replanting problems is solved
easily and kind of more
more easily than previous sort of
model-based multi-step-by-step
optimizations um but it's more than that
because
um as i mentioned this this linear rail
is approximate right we actually
understand the details of this
approximation where it fails
or what biases it has very well um so we
can predict particular errors
due to approximation that should make in
certain tasks that we can contrive
um and we expect that to show up as soft
biases or
increases at the rate of particular
types of errors that we can predict that
people make
um which roots in the use of this
default policy uh
to plan actions over multiple steps um
and we can actually observe these
experimentally in people
i don't ever talk about it but it's
recorded in this manager paper
um let me give you another example so a
more difficult class of
flexibility problems arises when instead
of rewards changing and that changes
so for instance in detour tasks animal
learns a
map with different paths goal including
the shortest one
and then in a transfer test uh the
shortest path is blocked and the animal
has decided where to go where i can find
the next shortest path
um so this is challenging for this class
of models because it actually changes m
right the thing that we've pre-computed
um so for instance being on one side of
the barrier now it doesn't predict
soon being on the other side of the
barrier that's a difference in the long
run dynamics so now
um and so we need to do sort of
additional computation to fix them up
but one of them's insights is the i
didn't mention the initial computation
of m
is actually a big matrix inversion um
and so
uh updating m is actually can be done by
sort of standard matrix and version of
entities
uh and it turns out that this case
corresponds to a very low rank
correction we're used to add a sort of
extra delta m to m
um to produce the new matrix that
includes this new single barrier
right a rank one matrix um
and so with this easy step um as you can
see we can actually reuse most of the
computation in m
and replan and find the next path best
path again
um the other thing that's neat about
this idea is that it suggests more
generally that our map
m for a new environment can be built up
confidentially by the sum of a set of
basis maps like delta m or the weighted
sum of them
and they're tied to features like
barriers that the animals could observe
and so the idea that these pieces could
themselves be kind of reused across
tasks and then the way you'll be able to
learn an environment
um is by recognizing them and adding
them to your map right so we think that
sort of confidential strategy will help
us learn new environments faster
working um this
idea also leads the last point i have
time to mention today which is
what this all has to do with
neuroscience so we think these basis
functions for the long run dynamics map
m uh explain responses in the toronto
cortex so
it turns out there's a long-standing
suggestion actually
that grid cells and internal cortex um
uh correspond to a basis for m
so the eigenvectors of m or long-run
maps like m
uh have this sort of spatially periodic
low frequency components just like grid
cells
um what was uh confusing in the previous
accounts um which our new account
explains
is why these grid cells in the brain are
so stable no matter where the animal is
trying to get or which paths he tends to
run
which has been demonstrated a lot so
this stability is actually not predicted
under previous theories
um because when the long run dynamics
change when the when the goals change
longer dynamics also change
and so the expectation of the m should
also
and they don't um a linear election
explains this with a new theory because
it reuses the same map
which was learned in the default policy
to optimize trajectories for different
goals
um this idea about low rank updates like
delta m also has a novel
correlating to rhino cortex um the
correction matrices like delta m are
actually produced sort of fields that
are yoked to the barrier
um and they actually look like a second
sort of less famous class of internal
cells for boundary cells
so we think what this is leading towards
is a common explanation for seemingly
different classes of internal responses
all of them understood as a set of basis
functions we're building up these
methods
okay so that's it so in short we suggest
a new way of
representing maps for planning that
makes it easier to reuse large chunks of
computational work across
tasks and still replant flexibly when
things change
on the theme with the symposium maybe
this is something we as neuroscientists
give back to ai in general as i
mentioned these problems of autonomously
managing one's own computations
are going to come up more consistently
in neuroscience than
ai and some of our ideas here in
particular this idea that we can update
m with a linear
delta m uh and build it up for basis
functions
to update maps and learn them um
i think is a novel both in computer
science and biology
this model also has more implications in
psychology that i didn't manage to talk
about
especially to questions involving
cognitive control and how you can sort
of effortlessly suppress
habits or reflexes or compulsions and
what that's going to cost you
so um feel free to check out the
pre-print and again thanks to finding
correct
okay so now i'll turn things over to our
leader grace swing of johns hopkins
for the interactive portion of the panel
so um feel free to check out the
pre-print again
okay so now i'll turn things over to our
leader
good afternoon let's give a round of
applause to our presenters
great work everyone and i also uh want
to convey my condolences to kanika rajan
and her family
for the untimely tragedy
i'd like to start off this q a with some
speakers
questions and directly addressed to our
individual presenters
and uh presenters will be able to chime
in on other
presenters answers so
why don't we start in order with conrad
first
conrad
with with complex neural systems there
will always be many confounders
is it realistic to expect studies of
population dynamics to control for
all of these confounders if so how do
you suggest
okay so to be clear my answer is no to
that
the long answer to that is indeed
there's so many confounders every
dimension
is in principle a confounder
and and therefore if you want the drive
towards
producing a causal model a model in
terms of information
transmission a model in terms of how
brain areas affect other brain areas
is probably impossible and that's not
necessarily a problem
like it just means that if we just have
observational data
we cannot get there it is possible if we
can part up and there's a lot of
great techniques now we have
optogenetics now we have tms
with tdcs with those techniques we can
get at that
but based on purely observational data i
believe that this is impossible now in
small systems maybe if you give me a
slice where i can
get rid of the confounders i can get
there but like for
the things that most people in this
audience are interested in that's
probably not difficult
any zack would you care to comment yeah
conrad smiling because he knew i would
have some chiming in about i mean this
is the nature of science right so
you make a hypothesis you see whether a
bunch of
um variables are explained by
the the model that you propose and so
you're going to have to make some
simplifying assumptions and under those
simplifying assumptions
you can potentially derive causal causal
models
they are simplifying assumptions they
can be falsified
and so that's uh that's what you have to
look for
perturbation is the gold standard uh but
there are
good ways of getting at least a decent
uh first guest at things
and we'll see what happens you know upon
further refinement
but so far we don't know if this is true
no like
at some level it's possible that if we
if we start with the
hypothesis and we test simple models
they approximate reality it's possible
that they're not
and so so at the moment we don't have
much evidence
how good the models are that we fit at
actually predicting causal effects it's
very rare that we have both
that we have an interesting model that
we fit and that we then test it
perturbatively
all right let me move on to the second
question for you conrad
is mesoscopic modeling justified by the
fact that neural computations seem to be
very
robust against noise in neuronal level
lesions for
many tasks yeah this is this this is a
fantastic question now like
it is absolutely true that if i take a
brain i take out a neuron
probably nothing happens it's also true
that
there's noise everywhere and it has
relatively limited effects
and yet kind of the question is does
that mean that we can then go from a
model that is
about the brain in terms of its whole
high dimensional glory to
a model that has far fewer dimensions
and i don't think this is a very good
argument and
and the reason for that is the following
if i take a neural network that i train
on something
i can also take out any one neuron
nothing happens to it
it's just that every neon there's
something different so the the the big
question that we in a way have to face
with
it in in the debate that we're currently
having is to which level can we
understand
brain computation in low dimensional
spaces or to which level are they in
high dimensional spaces
the fact that they are fault tolerant
doesn't suggest that computation is
necessarily low dimensional
and so in that sense no i don't think we
can take that as a justification
for the possibility of mesoscale
modeling
why does it not imply that conrad i
didn't understand the argument there
okay if you have a remember code it
means that you have a lower dimensional
structure there so
we could it's it's about the existence
of information and it absolutely shows
that the information that we have in a
given neuron isn't essential for the
overall calculation
that doesn't mean that any every channel
codes the same thing
it just means that the signal of
interest is contained in many
channels that there in no way means that
any of the channels are important like
let's let's take an example let's take
vason i see how far the screen is from
me
i can use texture for it and i can use
maybe
disparity for that those two are two
different channels both of them allow me
to do that it would be perfectly redone
and i would still know where the
where the screen is but it doesn't allow
me to say that
e that i can basically dump everything
together and have only one channel i
have a
disparity channel and i have a texture
channel and they both allow me to
estimate distance
all right conrad i'd like to move on to
the next presenter
thank you very much and we'll come back
to some of these points when we get to
the group discussion i think there's
more to be
said uh joseph we have a question for
you
do your models break in interesting ways
are there specific kinds of tasks eg
moving around corners
abandoning previous reward locations
that are more or less successful
i'd like to thank brad for this uh
interesting question about so this is my
my neural swarming model that he's
referring to um
and yeah so the model does break in
certain ways and what are the most
important
uh parametric dimensions along which it
breaks um that would have to do mostly
with
uh the the spatial scale at which the um
the kind of intrinsic or recurrent
swarming dynamics occur
and the scale at which the reward
approach dynamics occur
so there's a trade-off there and those
are both going to trade off with the
relative scale of the environment
relative to the number of
density of the storm and then the other
dimension would be
the the rate of learning so
there's learning rates on both the uh
performing and and the return
and and the uh reward approach um and so
you can trade off like what was between
kind of random exploration versus direct
exploration
based on on whether you're dominated by
uh the
recurrent learning or the fee for reward
learning
and so those kind of if you go to
extremes along uh those dimensions and
trade-offs
um you do get stuck in certain types of
dynamics or maybe these
where you get directed exploration or
the storm or doesn't zip to local
rewards and that
basically stay there um and we did
implement a feature where rewards could
be captured or memorized um so
the value basically goes to zero
short-term memory uh which enables uh
more long-term foraging behaviors
um and there are uh right is it
the the swarming dynamics kind of give
rise to the current dynamics of rights
kind of a diffusion almost a gaseous
diffusion
across the environment that helps you
get around corners and get
um you know to find your way through
like american maze or more complex
environments
um and so that's part of that spatial
scale trade-off of like
how how much pressure there is on that
side
um so what i showed was kind of like a
middle road
parameter
thank you joe i'd like to now move on to
a question from brad
uh pertaining to your reverse replay
does the reverse activity serve as
aryani's thread enabling theseus to back
out of the labyrinth
uh yeah i think that's exactly how we're
interpreting this but but it's really
important to note that we don't
uh we don't at this point have any any
data to directly support that this is
all correlative
um to really show that we need to to
directly
you know remove or force these reverse
sequences
um from happening uh but yeah
we we think that's exactly right so
these reverse sequences that happen
during behavior we believe are a way for
the
hippocampal network to encode the
reverse of what is actually happening
to support the idea that at some point
later on down the road when the rat is
paused the cells that are encoding that
reverse sequence during behavior those
are the cells that participate in the
reverse replay where the hippocampus
thinks about the entire path it just
took in the reverse order so yeah we
think this is a way
to retro retrospectively evaluate
the sources of some current outcome
thank you for the question
thank you like to now move to zach's
presentation
question here is how interpretable is
the message passing algorithm
would a smart human be able to
understand how the inferred network is
implementing computation via nonlinear
dynamics
especially when it's not a bayesian
inference
it's a great question thank you maming
um it depends on the particular
structure you know i think uh
understanding is kind of a funny word
it's like storytelling
we can find properties that are useful
for that
and by formulating things as message
passing you can actually
structure your knowledge in a useful way
it doesn't necessarily mean that you
understand every little nuance of things
and that way there would be some things
for us to learn but you know you can
find
uh for example in a in a graphical model
with loops you find that there's
an echo chamber effect where you you
have some information that could
reverberate around
if you're just using naive algorithms
but you might have
a memory of what messages were sent out
that you could then use to discount your
future
signals coming back in and that type of
thing could be
potentially interpretable by a human but
in order to discern that you'd actually
have to look at the content
of the actual nonlinear message passing
to tell a story about that
so in general it doesn't automatically
give you an interpretation
but it does reduce the space of things
that you have to explain
thank you zach and i like to move on
to nathaniel uh you have one question
how valid is the markovian assumption
that underlies most of the rl models
when we try to understand
behavior well it's not at all valid
if by what you mean is that the
input to these models should be the
animal's kind of raw sensory
environment clearly most tasks
are not markovian in that space um
on the other hand i think that uh
really whether using an rl model or just
you know having to solve the animals
the problem the animal has to solve you
have to map some representation of sort
of the current and past
events to choose actions to figure out
what to do to predict
and the question is what is the
representation
that you are uh
that you were using for that
decision-making and of course it has to
have
usually most tasks you know history in
it so the markov assumption just
specifies in a formal way what you think
the animal needs to
have to solve a problem and then the
question becomes how does the animal
brain construct a representation
not just of the sensory world but of the
uh
a memory as well and what parts of
memories of what can it use
to to make this principle hold true and
i for that i think it's perfectly valid
uh it's a research question uh part of
the learning problem is how do you
establish representation that does that
um but i think you have to and you can't
escape it i don't think it's like a
specific problem with our techniques to
the contrary i think it's
it's something that rl techniques expose
very clearly as a piece of the learning
problem
thanks thank you
at this stage i like to transition to
the more formal
group discussion and i'm going to start
off
with a uh a question
from i'm going to start with zach and uh
and then i'm going to ask joe in uh
conrad
to chime in and everyone else is welcome
to chime in thereafter
so here it is what do you consider to be
the biggest theoretical
theoretical gaps in understanding the
brain that are precluding
aiml from achieving human level
intelligence
and to fill these gaps is more big data
needed
that's an amazing question and you know
if we knew the answer to that
everybody would be happy
theory is is really happy about the
presence of all this big data but
it means that we need a lot more
creativity i think
there are a lot of neat tools that are
coming around and
new languages for expressing knowledge
if you ask me i think to
get a good understanding of intelligence
uh you need
statistics flexibility and some kind of
compositionality or symbolic computation
and i think that the brain does all
these things but in order to figure out
how the brain does these things we need
to have
massive scale recordings during complex
tasks
and i think that neuroscience has made
great strides by using
simple tasks but that time has passed
and there are many ways of solving one
of those tasks so if you really want to
challenge the brain to see what it's
doing
you have to give it a task where you
take away the sensory evidence and
reveal the internal model
and for that i think a moderate amount
of complexity is really important
now this also gets to the question of uh
that we were talking about before
in terms of redundancy and like what is
the dimensionality of the actual
dynamics that matter
and if you have interesting nonlinear
computations that are happening through
those dynamics
uh the more data you have the more
refined you can make your assessment
of how how the little uh nonlinear bends
in your functions matter
and that's especially important as we
move to higher dimensions
but we're always going to need some
assumptions under there because
there's no way we'll ever get enough
data to constrain
the dynamics of a very high dimensional
system
thank you zach joe
or conrad hi i was just i'm i'm muting
my
mic um yeah so this is a just a follow
on
from what jack said a transition of
sorts to naturalistic stimuli
of the very complex um behaviors and in
the sensory landscapes of animals
experience is something that that's
going to be really important
um and it raises the question of sample
complexity which is perhaps one of the
biggest gaps
between current and machine learning
approaches and what we kind of
understand about brains
animals do not see as many examples
as as modern deep learning networks do
they can learn and generalize very
quickly from a small number of examples
so how do they do that well they well
one major difference is that
you have dense activation across those
forward and backward passes
and kind of in these uh deep artificial
or deep hierarchical networks
machine learning but you don't really
see that kind of dense activation
um in much of a cortex and the brain
so you've got kind of sparsity and um
maybe sparsity is a
fundamental kind of enabler
hierarchical representations in the
brain and the ability
for as access uh the compositionality of
different hierarchical layers to quickly
transfer
learning from from one domain to another
domain
um so sample complexity and and how you
can solve the problem of generalization
through
changes through kind of through
understanding the sparsity of
connectivity and how that
connects to the sparsity of dynamics and
neural activity
on top of that structure um so that's
kind of a major
major gap and that also ties in with the
idea that i i i mentioned briefly my
talk of
time dependence so uh there's been
various attempts such as
recurrent neural networks and lstms of
getting uh time-varying uh learning and
and processing within artificial
networks um but there's
tremendous amount of complexity of
temporal dependence in the brain
including oscillations and synchrony and
phase coding in certain parts of the
brain at the hippocampus and other areas
so this is really a lot of different
mechanisms which are yet to be explored
in
the artificial domains which might
enable flexibility and reconfiguration
of basic computational units
great thank you and conrad would you
like to add to
this collection of gaps we've identified
first with sparsity and then with time
dependence
yeah i must say maybe
the the main problem is that we're
trying to achieve the wrong thing
so today's focus of much of
computational neuroscience is to get
that mechanism to get it like
little chains of causality and as i
argued it's very hard to get at
causality
but also that's not really what machine
learning wants from us at the moment so
if i build a deep learning system i put
a lot of effort into constructing good
cost functions
figuring out what the cost functions are
in the nervous system would be
super important for that field i worry a
lot about say
building uh building the right
architectures and
people worry a lot about those and we in
in in those we worry about optimizers
and in a way this disconnected the
questions that seem very attractive
from a machine learning perspective that
these connections don't drive
so much research at the moment i think
that that's really sad and so
i think if you ask me what's the main
missing point here
it is that there's this whole point
whole area at the intersection between
machine learning and neuroscience that
can be opened that doesn't have
the mechanism slash causality
flavor that neuroscience is usually
striving for
anyone else on the panel want to chime
in for normative models i gather
not necessarily normative models i i'm
just pointing towards models that are
organized in terms of cost functions
optimizers learning rules and
architectures
and this there are some that are
normative where you can say
you you have a cost function that mimics
someone's ecological niche
and there's some that are not normative
where it's like here's a function that's
good to optimize
there's everything in between now now
there's this for example inversely
that sounds normative
um to to me normative means two things
it means that there's something that's
optimized
and it also means that the thing that is
optimized
is a match to the problem that is to be
solved in the ecological list of someone
so in that sense like i use a slightly
different definition of normative
but right yes
i've been using the term rational to
mean you're optimizing maybe the wrong
thing
but it makes sense that you're
optimizing that thing because you have
the wrong assumptions
i i could come around to rationale as
as the name for this class of models
different communities
yeah i just want to uh remind the
audience it is one o'clock now
uh we will continue our discussion but i
just want to
make people aware that uh it is one
o'clock
and uh bye bye everybody
and so let's let's please uh continue
with with this
with this actually rather important
discussion because it's it sounds like
you know there's this disconnect between
the uh
the presenters and their perspectives uh
based on the answers that joe and zach
just presented
in the um in the rebuttal that conrad
just provided so i was wondering if
anyone wants to
to add another opinion or to help us
come to consensus today
we can be bold and try to come it would
be awesome to come to some consensus on
the gaps in approach that we recommend
i see nathaniel has his hands up go
ahead i mean i think one thing that i
heard from everybody which i think
everybody agrees
is that we don't just need more big data
know full stop right we need the right
data for the right questions and we're
discussing what those are
um i think there's this really kind of
naive idea that
no one here has expressed but i i feel
like i myself once believed
long ago and i think lots of people who
haven't thought about this
hard believe which is that we're just
gonna you know measure a bunch of stuff
about the brain and figure out how it
works and go tell
the professionals in engineering how to
solve their problem
um and you know the professionals
engineering are smart people who are
professionals who know a lot of stuff
and if you know big data is going to be
a piece of helping them from
neuroscience solve their problems it's
going to involve
us talking to them about what they need
and them talking to us about
you know what how we can interpret our
data and there's lots of opportunities
there
uh and i think you know big data and the
right tasks
is an important piece of that i think
figuring out where the problems actually
are in ai if that's what you're trying
to solve and asking those people as
conrad said is in other things i
i think in that respect i think that
everyone's right great mike chapman had
a question that actually relates to this
he said shouldn't the hypothesis the
search for hypotheses
be guided by structure and function
ontogeny phylogeny and other biology
things
and i think the answer is absolutely
and that's you know this there's some
like legacy code that we get that we
inherit that's not necessarily the best
of all
possible legacies but it's what we what
we managed to get from here to there and
paul chisek i think that's how you say
his name but i don't know has an
interesting theory about how the
different
parts of the brain are structured
according to actual ecological problems
that happened along the way of evolution
so i think that that's an
interesting architectural set of
constraints
connecting to what conrad had said as
well so that sounds like yet another
important gap
to understand the relationship between
structure and function
great with that i think i like to uh if
there's no other hands
i'd like to move move to uh another
panel question and this one will be
directed first have brad and then anyone
else feel free to
join in how can we translate decades of
spatial navigation studies into spatial
sensory and motivational signals to
explain foraging
under uncertainty in the context of
machine learning
uh yeah great thanks for that question
um
yeah so a lot of work on rodents and and
more recent work on humans has suggested
that
uh during periods of purposeful memory
retrieval
uh the hippocampus is really good at
generating
sort of predictive sequences so uh in
the rodent for example in an open field
where the rodent has to navigate to a
learned location
what we observe is during the periods of
of sort of deliberation before the
animal actually takes an action
there are brief sequences that encode
the spatial trajectory starting from the
animal and ending at that goal location
that presumably requires some knowledge
about the environment it presumably
requires some level
of learning uh we have not yet
quantified the extent of that
but presumably that that is required for
for an animal to
to engage in sort of purposeful memory
use
to retrieve the previously stored
information and meaningful
and presented in a meaningful way uh
during random forging though which i
think is part of that question uh we
don't see this we don't see this sort of
we still see sequences that are
expressed but they don't seem to
correlate with the animal's actual
behavior they seem to be
completely independent suggesting that
there might be two distinct mechanisms
one
in the hippocampus which is just
generating sequences of information that
might or might not lead to
important locations or or information
content
and another region maybe the cortex
that's listening to that
and evaluating the content or the
salience of those paths
to to you know decide whether or not it
should act upon that information
uh right so that would be that would be
my my answer to that that's that's what
i
i have gathered from the you know the
decades of work looking at sequential
reactivation in the hippocampus
i see nathaniel has a comment
go ahead nathaniel
do one thing to add to that which i
think this is the the history can you
hear me i have some network problems
the history of of hippocampus i think is
a good example
of zack's point that we want big data
kind of in the right tasks or
complicated tasks
um so i think uh
so much of the work on on almost all of
it
on animal uh representations of space
and hippocampus and replay and preplay
and all of it
occurs in the context of sort of minimal
behavioral
uh task for the animal right it's
basically random foraging uh brad's
study is
is one notable variant actually um
and and i think it's because the the
place fields were so exciting that
people became
part of sensory neuroscience like how
did they how did the question was
how do these neurons get their response
basically and that sort of dominated the
field for for decades and i think this
is a great example where
now it's time to sort of put them back
and ask how do animals use this stuff to
actually
behave i think that's a very exciting
question which again i think is a bit
in the spirit of the sort of thing that
zach was mentioning for instance
and would you have some thoughts about
new experiments of design
to run experiments with with rodents and
complex environments to get at these
questions
yeah i think you know in some ways to
some extent the kinds of experiments
that for instance joe was
uh modeling you know foraging for
rewards and dynamic environments
and studying the choices and the neural
representations and how
experience drives neurologic neural
activity and how neural activity plays
into subsequent choices
i think that's going to be where the
action is very exciting
i'd like to ask you a question as a
follow-up to that one of the things that
i find the most challenging is
how to think about learning in these
contexts because you only get
one shot to see the first shot at
something right so learning that the
process of learning you just
never get a lot of data about any one
thing that you've learned
how do you think about good tasks or
good experiments to design
a learning experiment that would
generalize
yeah i think i think to get that
question you need to be
able to monitor the same population of
neurons across long periods of time
across many different days or
repetitions of a novel task
so that you can monitor network activity
as the animal transitions from that that
task being novel to that task being
familiar so i think
long-term recordings are going to become
more important for for addressing that
point
so if that that would be really helpful
if you have something that the animal
learns slowly
but there are many things that an animal
learns quickly like they see something
for the first time and then recording
over time
is very difficult to like does it matter
yeah that's that's a fair point as well
yeah there are many many examples of one
trial learning
especially in their own literature um
right
for those tasks i imagine that it'll be
important to just record from a
sufficiently large number of rats that
you can identify in each rat the neurons
that are
uniquely encoding that experience so you
can see how their
how their patterns of activity or
potentially their connections or
functional connections between other
neurons
that also encode similar information how
those might change across that that
single experience
yeah i wanted to follow up on this
on the final point that we kind of need
data for
a really broad set of problems now like
it's it's and it's not enough that it's
just rich so
when it comes to one of the problems
that are really hard for ai at the
moment it's multi-task learning where
you learn one thing then you learn the
next thing and then you're not
on the top thing and for us humans it's
generally the case that like hey we kind
of learn stuff about the domain we keep
getting better
if we do that with our algorithms they
tend to get worse and then we use all
kinds of hacks to
to avoid them from getting worse and yet
for the nervous system it seems to be
very natural that it keeps getting
better
and i think basically therefore we are
so focused in neuroscience of giving one
experiment for a long period of time
maybe varying a very small thing
basically how animals deal
with learning different things one after
the other is one of the big
questions that we need to look much more
often
absolutely joe yeah you
yeah i wanted to follow up on i guess
the two previous points um
so so i had a study with uh jim
canarim's lab
we said he does more random foraging
experiments and rats
where i was able to establish a
behavioral relationship
um with these investigatory behaviors
where the rats will laterally scan their
heads back and forth
and i was able to show that that
persistent approx changes and
and place field uh math could be
associated directly with the singular
uh behavioral events so the animal would
stop from running
and just look out into the environment
and then and then on the very next
lap through one of these uh circular
closed loop tracks
um a place field would appear there and
that would be a stable persistent place
field
which um the long history of hippocampal
studies have suggested may be a basis a
neural basis
of episodic memory so that's kind of
like the canonical example of
one shot learning in mammals um so
there's a there's possibly a very strong
interplay
um between uh volitional actions and
behaviors uh with respect to the
environment
um and and and how uh one-shot learning
is implemented in
the campus and perhaps other parts of
the brain
and then this also ties into the idea of
sparsity versus density so
um that these typical memory networks
are sparse
maybe two to five percent of possible
connections actually existing
um and so how does that a
structural sparsity enable um
the learning of these kind of very high
dimensional high order
um uh events across an animal's lifetime
in a way that does not give rise to
catastrophic forgetting
um that you might see in these uh dense
artificial neural networks
um so maybe sparsity and kind of these
uh
pre-configured networks indicated by the
preflight phenomena
um that have been uh revealed um kind of
show that maybe this is
underlying kind of dark tool repertoire
of activity which can be
um which can be brought forth by a
fairly simple
um but uh transient and powerful uh
learning uh episode
thank you joe i think that was a great
summary of ideas i'd like to to shift
gears and take one audience question at
this time
this has to do more with optimizer
functions
so what is the optimization function
which see it seems to me that a lot of
optimization approaches are defined by
the observer
in that sense it is a subjective
phenotype
how can we introduce evolution into
optimization
this question is from dr fidel santamar
maria
well there are multiple ways now how
evolution plays a role so the first one
is that if i try to understand a new
animal that i might not know so much
about
i will look at the ecological niche
i assume that evolution has allowed the
animal to be good at the things the
animal is doing maybe like
forage efficiently maybe solve those
problems
and then in a way um evolution gives me
a justification about why
an optimization function should have a
certain role but there's a very
different way how we can think about it
where you can say
um there exists the need to ev to
optimize different things
in a in an animal life and
in the way the animal interacts with its
environment and maybe
therefore there's different optimizers
in different parts of the brain
and evolution has kind of given us this
collection of
optimizers somehow jointly and
in in in that sense we can we might
rather
ask for like which were the optimization
problems that were important in our far
past so it's it's a very rich
question indeed i see zach has his hands
up
yeah it's more a follow-up question to
that so if you think about
multiple optimizers can't you just put
all of that together into one
big optimization that's context
dependent and therefore depends on
more of the state of the world
again right what's that yeah in
principle yes not like
but the question is if this is a good
way of thinking about it so
if we if we have this strict
optimization idea where you have one
cost function that you optimize
then it it it robs you of certain kinds
of flexibility and there might be
computationally much harder now you can
say
that if i optimize a given thing at a
given point of time now like right now
i'm not maybe optimizing my food intake
and i might dedicate absolutely no like
cognitive resources to optimizing my
food intake and similarly like if you're
like a baby if you're at a different
developmental
stage you might want to run a very
different cost function that you
optimize so
this idea that this one global cost
function makes
things computational harder it also
makes it easier maybe to game you know
like if i know that you have one global
optimization
function then it might be easier for me
to predict you so there can be other
there can be other reasons why you
wouldn't want to follow a strict
optimization framework
so anyone else breaking optimization
into
separate optimizers then it you're
imposing some kind of modularity
right and so that really that's this
gives you a hierarchical
structure and then then you get involved
in what am i going to plan like
do i have long term planning over which
optimization am i going to run
and then you have the local optimization
like now that i've conditioned on that
and i think that there's good evidence
that we do conditioned perception
and we do conditioned action like we're
not constantly planning
everything we have some but i think a
lot of that can be subsumed under
resource constraints
we're not able to optimize we're only
able to locally optimize
and then the question of what is the
optimizer kind of boils down to what are
the constraints
yeah i mean like we're fully in
agreement here
well we can't have that i'm sorry about
that
i'm getting hungry uh-oh
i guess at this point there's sort of
one point that we haven't had a chance
to talk about today which has to do with
uh comes from conrad's presentation in
which he describes
need to be able to measure information
flow in the brain
and i've not heard much of that
discussion uh during the panel
and i think we're probably going to have
to wrap up soon so i wanted to
open the floor to see if people think
that's an important theoretical gap that
we need to address
in addition to all the things that we've
talked about today
but to be clear i mean my point was that
it's kind of impossible so
um the question is do people disagree
with it being mostly impossible and do
people think that
that it would really advance us if we
could get there
uh well my my whole presentation was
predicated on the idea that there is
information flow and information comes
in
over time so i i think yes there is you
know it gets to
some parts of your brain first it gets
to some ideas first and it takes time to
make connections
you know maybe you could even invoke
thinking fast and thinking slow
under some conditions it's going to be i
agree
impossible with the amount of data that
we have to discern some of the fine
details of that information flow
but in other cases i think it's pretty
clear that you can that you can find
the information flow you know some of
the early work in very fast perception
you can measure just synaptic delays of
how long it takes to get there
and while that's not a knockout for any
model at all
under what we think of as reasonable
models for like how long a synaptic
delay takes and whether you would have
sort of retroactive like backwards time
uh backwards signals propagating with
faster delays than other backward
signals i mean it would take a lot of
weird
modeling to be consistent with the
forward flow of information that we
observe
in terms of experiments and still say oh
well there's a confounder
in time so i think information flow can
be very well defined
and i think it's a useful concept that
we should push on
i agree we find and it it's a useful
concept the question is
under which circumstances we can
practically measure it
i think joe had a comment uh before we
go on to your next question joe did you
want to comment
basically probably what conrad was about
to say which is that so are we talking
about a distinction where yeah there is
this
uh information flow or return network
that's very difficult to interpret
externally but maybe that's the critical
computational basis for the animal to
create you know relevant information
that's meaningful as far as future
actions and cognition
um versus our ability to observe the
brain of another animal
as an external party um and interpret
that within our own
uh experimental information context um
so both
so you could have you know these
critical types of information
that talked about but then also not but
have this kind of maybe intractable or
very difficult problem
of measuring it and understanding what
our perturbations are doing to the
complex information flow within these
systems
conrad well
i think i think we're all in agreement
here wow this is fantastic
one of you care to summarize and
prioritize the four main gaps
to to bridge machine learning and
theoretical neuroscience and
experimental
work ideas
we need more ideas and more data
and and and we need to rethink the old
ideas
do we need to worry about the the
mismatch and dimensionality between
ml systems and the brain i believe
there's this
there's there's still i think
disagreement between the three
theorists who presented where uh
yeah i i agree that they're i mean it's
not clear that there's really a
fundamental mismatch if anything the
brain is
is i mean they're both big dimensional
right the question is
is can you understand it in terms of
simpler terms
uh it does you might mechanistically
need
a lot of units in order to give yourself
the fertile
soil to give the computational dynamics
that you want
that's sort of the way that i think
about it if you had an arbitrary neuron
uh with you know multi-dimensions etc
then
you might not need so many neurons but
when you have constraints on the biology
and constraints on the functions
then having a lot of neurons is just a
way of enacting the right kind of
non-linear computational dynamics
in some lower dimensional space but you
you also have to get to that lower
dimensional space by selecting the right
features
and so the input is high dimensional so
i think that there are roles for
both of those kinds of computations
and the question is where we need low
dimensionality now like
uh we might assume low dimensionality in
the processing and i guess i'm just more
pessimistic than zach there
or alternatively you might assume low
dimensionality on the side of
learning rules and architectures and and
that might be
that might be in fact the place where a
lot of us might be able to meet
yeah i mean i would certainly agree that
you get inductive biases from both of
those architectures and plasticity rules
absolutely
well great i think we're well over time
so
if anyone has anything they want to say
show me give me your hand
otherwise i oh zach has something he
wants to say
i want to say thank you grace for
organizing this really fun panel
discussion
and thank you thanks very much for
listening
thank you everybody we'll see you guys
soon virtually
take care